We're now going to take a look at some of the optimization
view modes Unreal Engine 5 provides
to help us visually debug performance issues
or better understand areas that could be performance
issues inside of our levels.
The first one we're going to talk about
is lighting complexity.
But before we do that, I want
to pop over to the editor really quick
and show you where a lot of these view modes live.
And that is underneath the view mode settings here,
optimization view modes.
And we have our lighting complexity, light map density,
stationary light overlap, shader complexity, shader complexity
in quads, quad overdraw, material, LWC, function usage,
and some others for texture streaming.
So what does this lighting complexity do?
Well, lighting complexity is a visualization mode
that helps you show how many non-static lights, which
are dynamic or movable lights, are affecting your geometry.
It's a really quick way to understand where you're seeing
lighting might be heavy and, therefore, more performant
expensive.
To interpret this, Unreal uses a scale that starts at black
and goes to white.
And as the scale starts to approach white,
the values that it's showing us
indicate the light is growing more and more expensive.
We can use this mode to help visualize areas of our levels
that are being hit by multiple lights
so we can make better decisions about how to adjust lighting
in that area.
Oftentimes, it can be difficult to understand
how your lights are interacting with one another.
And this tool helps you make those decisions.
Let's take a look at how that works in the editor.
So again, we're going to come up here to our lit.
We're going to go up to our optimization view modes.
And we're going to go to our stationary light overlap.
I'm just going to hold down L and click.
Not stationary, light overlap.
I'm sorry.
We're going to come over here and we want our light complexity.
There we go.
And then I'm going to just hold down Alt and move and move.
Keep holding down Alt. That's going to make some copies.
So what I meant earlier when I said more informed choices
is if we come here to our light attenuation radius
and say we set this to something like 100,
you can see here now we have our light.
It's still kind of expensive.
But as we move other lights around,
or maybe we set this to like 500, you can see here
now we can make a little bit more informed choice
about how these lights are going to interact
with one another.
Maybe we have something like this.
Oops, not like that.
I wanted to grab that axis and just move it over like this.
So we have something like that that's giving us
the lights where we need them.
But we have a better idea of how everything
is interacting with one another.
So remember some things to take away from this.
Keeping your lighting complexity and the dark blue
to bright green range for optimal performance.
And red areas are warnings that it's time to simplify
or optimizing your lighting setup in that particular area.
The next optimization of view mode I want to talk about
is quad overdraw.
So quad overdraw is a visualization mode
that helps you understand how efficiently your geometry
is being rendered on the GPU.
GPU processes pixels in a two by two quad,
not individual pixels.
This means that when you have very small
or thin triangles, smaller than a two by two pixel area,
the GPU has to process the full quad for each one,
which results in a lot of extra work,
even though most of those pixels
might not actually contribute to the final image.
This matters because high quad overdraw means your GPU
is wasting cycles, shading tiny triangles,
which can seriously impact performance,
especially when we have very dense, detailed scenes.
This is also super common in high poly models,
foliage and nanite fallback messes
that are not properly optimized.
The quad overdraw view mode shows which messes
are suffering from excessive overdraw.
Blue indicates low overdraw,
which is good and what you want to see.
Green to red indicates high overdraw,
meaning the GPU is doing a lot of unnecessary work
in those areas.
You can reduce quad overdraw by using LODs
to remove or simplify small thin triangles
that can't be seen at distance
or optimizing meshes to avoid excessive detail
in areas that don't contribute visually.
Ensuring that meshes also have proper distance
for the view that they are from the camera can also help.
The key thing that you should take away from this
is if you want quad overdraw to be as blue as possible,
this means that your geometry is efficient
and your GPU will render your scene
much faster and smoother.
The nanite visualization mode that is available
shows you how nanite is being constructed for your scene.
Let's take a look at these individually,
starting right up here with the triangles.
So these triangles displays all of the triangles
that the nanite meshes in your current scene.
This is useful for seeing mesh density
and verifying how nanite is handling high poly geometry.
If you zoom in, you can actually see
how many triangles nanite is processing
often in the millions.
And this is really cool
because it's still doing all of that
while maintaining real-time performance.
Now the clusters view shows colored groupings of triangle
that nanite uses internally.
Each color represents a cluster
or a logical group of triangles
that nanite renders as a single unit.
This view helps you understand
how nanite's cluster-based rendering system
is organizing and batching geometry
for performance efficiency.
Instances visualize a unique color
to each instance in the scene.
This is useful for identifying
and verifying instanced static meshes,
especially when working with
instanced static mesh components
or hierarchical instanced static mesh components.
The primitive view colors all components
of an instant mesh with the same color.
Unlike instances view,
this differentiates individual instances.
This mode will help you see all components
that share the same base mesh
as one unified color group.
Overdraw, which is very important,
visualizes how much overdraw is happening
in your scene geometry.
You'll notice that a smaller,
closely stacked objects like foliage
or detailed props will create more overdraw
than larger single surface meshes.
This mode helps identify areas
where rendering efficiency can be improved.
Material ID view shows distinct colors
for each material ID applied to nanite meshes.
This is great for checking material assignments,
multi-material setups,
or ensuring that materials are applied consistently
across complex assets.
Raster bins shows you programmable GPU features
such as tessellation and other rasterization tasks.
This is primarily used for debugging
advanced rendering paths
and verifying how nanite is dividing geometry
into programmable raster events.
The evaluate world position offset view
shows which meshes or materials
are using world position offset.
This is important because WPO can affect
nanite performance and stability.
Nanite doesn't support all types of vertex deformation
and using this view can help you quickly identify assets
relying on WPO or world position offset
so you can quickly adjust them if needed.
Remember that this view mode here
can only be activated if you are utilizing
a nanite mesh inside of your scene.
So if I come back over here,
I'm gonna come to my lighting complexity,
just go back to lit,
and if we come here to our nanite and we go to overview,
I don't have any type of nanite mesh in here,
but if I came into and added a,
let's see here, we'll just right click
and we'll do nanite.
Nanite is enabled on this and I pull this in,
then we're gonna get this view populated
with a nanite mesh right there.
So remember that if you're not seeing anything,
it's probably because you do not have
a nanite mesh placed inside of your scene.
Now, one of the things that I want to call out
specifically with nanite is nanites overdraw.
Now, once you've determined that nanite
may be causing performance issues,
the overdraw visualization tool can help you pinpoint
where those problems are.
We use this tool after profiling confirms
that nanite is the source
of your performance bottlenecks,
and it's designed to help show where overdraw is occurring
and how it's impacting nanite's efficiency.
What it does is it highlights areas
where nanite is doing extra rasterization work.
Basically that means areas where multiple layers
of geometry overlap or where there are small triangles
that are densely packed.
Now, some amount of overdraw is normal and expected,
especially in complex scenes.
However, excessive overdraw leads
to higher nanite culling and rasterization costs,
as well as reduced effectiveness
of nanite's independent scene scaling.
Essentially, the more overdraw you have,
the less efficient nanite can batch renders and clusters.
To interpret this view, we use it to identify areas
with dense or overlapping meshes,
small geometry that might be unnecessarily detailed,
and regions where simplifying assets
or adjusting placement could reduce overdraw.
Remember, blue indicates low overdraw, which is good,
while red and orange show heavy or expensive areas.
Remember that we wanna use this mode
only after we have profiled to target performance issues,
specifically tied to nanite,
and that some overdraw is unavoidable,
and minimizing it will help maintain efficient scaling
and ensure your scene continues to render smoothly
and cost efficiently.